So, for our last quiz of the unit, I want to go back to the menu example we
started with and ask you to define classes that provide behavior that will allow
us to represent main dishes and appetizers. So, both main dishes and appetizers
have some properties in common. They all have names and prices, and they both
might have a description. As well as an indication whether they're appropriate
for vegetarians or not. These have default values of None and False. A MainDish
comes with sides, and the default number of sides is 0. An Appetizer does not
come with any sides, but it serves a variable number of people, the default
being 1. So, your goal is to find a dish module that will provide this behavior,
it will define types for at least the MainDish and Appetizer, we'll be able to
create a MainDish. Passing in a name, a price, and then optional description and
vegetarian parameters. When we print out a MainDish, we'll see the name of the
dish, followed by the name of the price. If there is a description, we'll see
that. Here's another example of a MainDish. This one has two sides and is
vegetarian. And when we print this out, we'll see the star, meaning it's
vegetarian. And that it has two sides. We can also create Appetizers. And
appetizers have names, prices, might have a description, might have vegetarian,
and might have the number of people they serve. And we can print out an
Appetizer, and it'll print out the name, the price, extra information like a
dish would, as well as the number that it serves. Here's another example. We're
creating an Appetizer with a description that serves three and we'll see it
print out the description followed by the serves. So, your goal is to define a
module that provides this behavior and to do it in a way that reuses code as
much as possible. You want to avoid having any unnecessary duplication of code.
Doing this well will take advantage of several of the things that I've
introduced in this class.